most of you know I am Virginia Lanka's
the career development specialist in the
bioinformatics program here and our
Thursday conferences it have been great
at highlighting the research that goes
on internally my purpose in bringing our
three illustrious speakers here today is
to kind of expand your perspective to
see exactly what industry is doing in
terms of research innovation and how the
science is being translated into
products services and policy in some
cases and the computational and the
clinical side I've tried to include both
today so and since I am the quasi
moderator here kind of like last night
in Nevada in case any of you watched
I'll be kinder after I'd ask you to hold
your questions and then at the end I'm
gonna get to ask three questions first
and then I will turn it over to the rest
of you huh
okay so bill is going to introduce now
from left to right Cormac
great Thank You Virginia and thank you
for organizing this these are always
well attended events I'm sure the pizza
has nothing to do with it as we've
learned in recent months but anyways
this is interesting I hope not only for
students and fellows but but also for
faculty to hear what well one of our
grads one of our kind of longtime
adjunct faculty and a new friend to the
department will have to say about
working in industry so yeah I'm just
going to do these introductions really
briefly so dr. McCormick maybe some of
you know when he was here as a PhD
student and an NLM fellow and graduated
from the program and has gone on to a
number of different jobs he actually did
some teaching as an adjunct faculty as
well his dissertation work applied human
factors engineering to the socio
technical factors that shaped local
workflows and he currently is director
of clinical informatics at the Central
Oregon independent practice association
in Bend which I imagine he'll talk about
in the middle is dr. Rahila Solari
natera who's director of bioinformatics
at natera a company where she leads a
team working on CT DNA based tests for
monitoring cancer she has 10 years of
experience in cancer computational
biology developing computational methods
and analytical techniques for
understanding the genetics of cancer
which I was getting increasingly
important she has a PhD in computer
science from Simon Fraser University up
the road in British Columbia with a
background on data structure and
algorithm design she also spent some
time after her PhD at the National
Center for Biotechnology information
NCBI which is part of the NLM and she
was a
research fellow there in postdoc fellow
in abouts a glow in the box on Ehlo lab
at stanford university i hope i
pronounced that right and and then our
third panelist again many of you know
because she has intermittently taught
and participated in research projects
around the department for a number of
years dr. Nancy Vukovich who currently
works at Campea focusing on
understanding computer consumer needs
and using human centered designed to
drive innovation many of us know her for
her long-standing work at Intel where
she was part of the health and life
sciences group and worked on technology
solutions to support provider's she
holds a PhD in medical anthropology from
the University of Arizona so I will
alright by unanimous vote I'm the non
informatics gets me first and as you
heard I'm a medical anthropologist and
so in a way a computational analyst but
using completely different kind of data
than you might be accustomed to but
still kind of looking at a lot of
diverse information and trying to make
some sense out of it
so I think that that's where we have
some alignment but what I'm going to be
talking to you about today is a couple
of places that I have worked Intel and
now at cambia and our use of informatics
as we try to either develop project
products or to develop services in the
case of cambia but let's get into that a
bit so at Intel health and life sciences
we used computational analytics to help
define some of the to help advance I
would say some of the work that we were
doing in both genomics and an imaging to
develop algorithms that might help to
diagnose pathology in imaging and also
to work with a lot of folks here
actually to understand more about
genomics and how we could apply AI to
understanding of that massive data set
we also used it in a slightly different
fashion to help us with some product
design we did a lot of work when I was
early at Intel in the space of
caregiving and aging in place and so we
were looking at questions about how can
we use ambient data or data collected by
sensors distributed throughout a home to
help do things like diagnose decline
very early even before it was clinically
identifiable and also to help to
identify who might be at risk for things
like Falls so once again we had our
scientist taking diverse sets of
information and trying to find patterns
in it trying to understand how we could
develop services and products related to
that that could be implemented in the
home or in a more clinical setting a lot
of the work that we also did was on how
to use that data to help not only
caregivers in the sense of professional
caregivers but also family members in
terms of doing things like reminding
people about medications that need to be
taken or to be able to identify when
things like appliances
left on or doors were left open once
again in the service of kind of defining
what a product space might look like in
terms of caregiving or Aging in place or
even chronic disease management so that
was I was doing like a lot of drinking
but from the firehose at that point
about technology as well as informatics
and trying to understand how the
insights that we were driving from
watching people on the ground do they go
about their daily life the information
we were getting from the sensors in
people's homes we're establishing
something that amounted to ground truth
and that could then be used to build
these kind of services or products that
made valuable resources available to
people throughout both the spectrum of
individuals as well as as professional
caregivers the kind of use that I see
informatics having at cambia is slightly
different we do have a consumer products
division and they're using some of that
information for product development but
I see it more from an organizational
perspective being used in my current
situation I I interface perhaps a little
bit less on a day to day basis with with
our informatics folks but still have a
good awareness and working relationship
with them and their insights really
provide a lot of information to the
organization as well as to individual
groups that might be trying to plan
services or products so on a you know a
daily basis there's information coming
to us about how our members are using
particular kind of services as well as
how our internal systems are responding
to number needs and other kinds of
business needs so that becomes a vital
part of decision making it becomes a
vital part of our strategic planning in
knowing how these different kinds of
operational things are working so that
we can make adjustments to them as
needed resource them appropriately or to
make changes in terms of either you know
vendors we might use or the process we
go about training our people to provide
different kind of services so I would
say that you know it's really kind of an
integral part of the business that we do
not only in planning for the future but
in monitoring on a day to day basis and
a little more in depth about the kind of
skills that our informatics teams have
within cambia or that really there's
also obviously understanding of advanced
analytics but also things like how you
would use data analysis applications how
you do data extraction all that kind of
stuff that you would imagine someone
coming out with a degree in informatics
may have but I would also say that
there's in addition to all of that
there are skill sets that we're looking
for that kind of span these kind of more
technical kinds of tools that you might
have or understandings that you might
have and learn in a classroom and those
have to do with more of how you interact
with our customer base so are you
customer focus so not just this is the
information but how might we use that to
change what we're doing and that's
that's where my team and these teams
interface so we might be able to
understand for example that there's a
problem with people accessing data off
of our website being able to use that in
some actionable way that would then come
to folks like my team in our digital
team to say how might we improve that
what kind of human Center design
processes might we use to make a change
in that and then how can we use
informatics to monitor whether those
changes are actually having a positive
effect on people but there's also as
part of the values I would say that we
have as an organization within cambia is
kind of looking at how we might use the
information that we develop in a way to
maybe enhance trust with our members as
opposed to degrade that so we have a
very strong interest in how we if we're
using patient data to create
personalized experiences how we are also
protecting that data and not selling it
not doing other things that might be not
necessarily acceptable to our membership
so there's there's a heavy emphasis on
that as well as within the organization
and you know I would say the other
aspect that is a very important
consideration is using this information
for problem-solving again not just a
flag that something's happening here or
something's happening there but being
able to look across those flags and say
there's something systemic going on here
what do we need to do to change how
we're doing and how I mean
how might we approach that differently
as we go into the future the other piece
that we are strongly moving toward and I
think this is really how the workplace
in general is moving is again not just
that an information system one
department might flag something and
someone else over here might but either
in identifying it or identifying the
solutions for that how can we be
cross-functional and collaborative
across our different divisions to make
those a more efficient as well as
effective kind of solution that we're
driving toward and once again that's
where my team interfaces and when we're
looking at you know how can we apply
human Center design methods how can we
think about the design of this in a way
that is collaborative and more systemic
than just kind of one off point
solutions
the last thing I wanted to point out to
you was because we I know we were
talking about skills and what kinds of
things how informatics is might be able
to step into a more less of a research
setting and more of a corporate setting
and what I was looking at here is
something that came from the the future
of jobs report from the World Economic
Forum and it's talking about transitions
in terms of skill sets not just hard
skill sets but soft skill sets that
people need as we move into 2020 and
beyond and I think what you're seeing
here is a shift between those two
categories is really an advancing of
things like not just how you do complex
problem-solving which is something that
your degrees and the work that you're
doing here should certainly enable you
to have but also critical thinking and
creativity because again the kind of
solutions that are really going to be
effective moving forward are not just
like point solutions that okay we're
fixing this problem but looking very
critically at what's the real root cause
of this what is the real problem here
and and that's again where the interface
with Design Thinking comes in play
because that's that's a core tenet of
doing design thinking is not just
looking for a surface problem but really
looking at the insights beneath it and
what are the core problems so I think as
you develop that and the kind of work
that you're doing you might think about
it in the work that you're doing in a
very
sort of prescribed kind of way based on
the kind of assignments that you have or
even thesis or dissertation that you're
working on but I would invite you to
kind of like look at other things as
well look at how it might be approached
from a different perspective a different
discipline and see how incorporating
some of that thought process might make
you help you to come to a Richard
solution based on looking at what the
core problem is that with that
if there any questions now we're happy
to entertain those along the way I know
there's gonna be time afterward as well
just start telling the story of like how
I got to where I am today I when I was
in my high school I found that I have a
very very special interest for
mathematics so I was enjoying doing Matt
more than anything that might sound lame
but I'm gonna tell you that I was not
that into that much into art I was not
that much into music I was not into
video game I was not really doing other
things that most teenagers would enjoy
what I was a lot enjoying just doing
mathematics like I would have spent my
weekends basically going to library
getting some advanced mathematics that
would people do in college and just read
it okay yeah that's what I did so based
on that my high school teachers they
recommended me I should do pure
mathematics for college but I was like
mmm no that's not what exactly would
food fulfill me I want to do something
that's more applied because I want to
see the effect of it and people's life
and so I after like thinking a lot I
chose computers computer engineering
which I think it was very smart and
lucky move for me back then I did my
undergrad and I definitely enjoyed
learning computer engineering coding
through the nights and just debugging my
codes but again I feel that okay this is
not enough I might be able to go and
work for like big companies like for
example Google but is this really what I
want to do I want to do is I was
thinking is still I want to do something
that has more effect on people's life so
I ended up choosing by informatics and
again like that was a great event enough
great for me I enjoy doing my PhD and
after that I could have stayed in
academia and do more research and keep
publishing and scientific papers but I
felt like when I was talking to my
mentors I told them that I want to be
part of a product I want to see I want
to do the research of course I want to
do it in a way to miss out but I want to
be part of development of a product I
want to see that one day there is a
product that I contributed in to
developing it it's in the market and
people are using it either it's like I
don't know the woman I've drugged or
test I want to see that people are
actually using it and that would be
great for me so what happened is that I
Joe I joined her in 2014 and I I was in
a research team and I was working on
like different ideas that what that we
we had for building a test for cancer
monitoring we we were successful in
building a prototype it was just like
basically the codes that I've that I
rode and I worked with our biology team
we did for our first real patient we
tested it on one of our co-workers that
sample his father had cancer and we just
wanted to see how these cancer treatment
is going if the treatment or chemo is
working for this person or not
I remember that I just like use my
prototype cause and I analyzed the test
and I saw the result and I walked to
desk and I told him that I think I am
done analyzing your dad sample and I am
very very confident that your dad is
cancer-free the sample looks clean he
stood up and he hugged me it was the day
before Thanksgiving and he was just so
excited and said that her hello this was
the best you could have give me just a
day before Thanksgiving I'm gonna just
deliver this message to my family and
that's the best and that day I felt like
this is it I'm ready to die
I got what I wanted to do in life I'm
good and it's for me it was really like
that I I wanted to see that if I finally
I contributed making something that it
has real effect on people's life so I'm
gonna give you an introduction to an
attorney I'm gonna go over like our main
products and I will stop and point into
where my informatics can contribute to
each product okay our company started in
2004 based on and personal history a
co-founder his daughter had sorry his
sister gave birth to a baby boy and boy
had Down syndrome which died just six
days later this was very devastating for
his family and and our co-founder
decided that okay that is not acceptable
in 21st centuries we should have a
proper test for Down syndrome so he came
up with a he called a few of his friends
and they just work together and this is
startup and they built a genetic testing
company today we after 16 years right we
we've been able to analyze more than two
million samples there are many countries
around the world who are using our tests
and it helps basically specifically for
women sold on a cancer monitoring
our company is based on very interesting
technology which is a cell-free DNA
testing I will check I'm gonna tell you
a little bit about it later
it has application in prenatal testing
in organ transplant as as well as cancer
all the tests that we have right now in
market they they have a specific they
have some license or certificate
probably you haven't heard about this
license or certificates but these are a
few regulation that each test should
follow there are specific validation
that a test should pass versus a product
a clinical product should pass to get
that specific certificate this my son
just like procuracy and boring but
believe me it is not that boring even
from a computational side because when
in order to get the certificate first
you really need to really understand
what is this product and then understand
how I can I can do the validation to
pass is the requirement and guess who is
doing all these data analysis of course
the bioinformaticians it it is quite
actually interesting to to understand
both how the the test or the product
works and also what are the requirements
for each one of this certificate and
these certificates are definitely
valuable because they they build trust
from all around the world and people and
different laboratories are willing to
use those so now about cell free DNA
basically every part of our body right
when the souls die they release their
pieces of DNA into blood so now when you
get a blood draw from a person you can
see all these pieces of the end there
isn't there not like a complete
genome it's just in two pieces which are
about like 150 bass it's very short
right but I still if you come up with a
nice work to on technology you should be
able to McLaws of lots of information
out of these pieces of DNA it has
application in prenatal and cancer an
organ transplant and that's how our
products are open so I'm going to tell
you okay so how the ni PT test work I
don't know if any of women here in this
room have got pregnant and I've done
this as well I personally have done this
test that I designed myself which was
very interesting so the Veda voice when
when women are pregnant in their blood
not only there is maternal feelings but
also there are about like 10% fetal DNA
so the way that where the test works is
that we get a blood draw then in the lab
from mom in the lobby extract all this
Venus which is the mixture of maternal
and fetal DNA it's a mixture
there is no flag on them that says oh
this thing is coming from mom this Venus
comes from baby hard works is that first
we we amplify a specific set of
predefined set of business and guess who
chose those names who went to 1000
genome genomes project database and
decided that which snips are the bestest
needs to to be used for this test James
Madison's right and then who design
these primers five madison again so what
we do after that we we sequence and a
sample and we perform QC which is
designed in
reviewed by a gang computational thing
and then we if we look at the imbalance
between the ally ratio I don't know if
have you guys ever looked at like a
mixture and sequencing data but for
normal healthy human beings we expect
that all the snips are either they have
a little frequency either zero percent a
hundred percent or 50 percent but if
when we see something a little bit
imbalance right say that instead of 50
percent we see like 60 percent it tells
you that oh you don't have equal amount
of both copies of a DNA it tells you
that there is some something going on so
we apply our algorithm and we come up
with a risk factor the tells how much
what is the probability that the fetus
has some genetic disorder I didn't
mention the work that other teams are
doing of course of course everybody else
in the company contributed to these
tests but I'm just I just wanted to like
point more about the bioinformatics
contribution which i think is helpful
here
for students here okay so so there are
other companies who doing this similar
tests but it's the the the technology
behind it is quite different they
usually look at the imbalance of the
amount of reads that they get from a
specific region and if they see more
reads or less reads they would consider
it as a sign of amplification or
deletion and again if if any of you here
ever worked with them an external
sequencing data either for germline
calling or Samadi why I'm calling should
be familiar already with different
basically tools or techniques that have
been used for semicolon so let's escape
that and now this is this one is about
the cancer monitoring test that I
mentioned
oh if you want to review the workflow of
this one this is a by any means by any
definition its a super personalized test
how it works is that we get a biopsy
from from a person who's already
identified and diagnosed with cancer the
sequence of biopsies we identify
specific somatic mutations for that
patient and we build a personalized set
of assay for this patient if we keep it
in the lab and every time in the future
when the patient send us the blood drop
we will apply this our assay to figure
out what is the level of cancer
basically for this patient um the test
is quite nice for patients and for
physicians why because usually right now
if a patient has cancer and they go
through treatment and they want to see
if the treatment is working or they've
been cured for so many years but they
still want to know am I so good is this
something coming back is everything fine
they need to do either CT scan MRI and
this type of test it cannot happen very
frequently because of all the cost and
also the side effect that you might have
depending on the cancer type there is a
regulation like for example for
colorectal cancer they can only do these
tears every eighteen month right so
currently cancer patient correct they
need to wait 18 months to get a green
light at okay everything is good
everything is fine but with this blood
draw there's no problem they can do it
every month right it might be too much
but they can do it as often as they want
just to have a peace of mind that okay I
mean still in there is no sign of
relapse or anything like that but what
make it
also interesting for insurance company
and for market is the cost of it
definitely cost of just processing a
blood test is much much less than doing
serious scam but what is interesting is
that at every step of this test
informatics is a very very important
module and from the very beginning
analyzing the whole exome sequencing
this is a computational heavy work then
basically choosing the best set of
mutations and then monitoring them in
plasma and calling those variants
detecting them in plasma these are all
computational and informatics modules
that need to be done by what people will
actually have a background and
experience in this pool and these people
are called by implementations right so
there are there's just a lot of I would
say it's it's a there is just a lot of
work that can be done by bio foundations
and different for different products in
in biotech and that makes it more
interesting so at the end I'll just skip
and I would go through like job
description that we have four by four
senior population scientists that
nurture their virus requirement but I
would tell you that the most important
thing that I think as like at least like
a junior bioinformaticians the person
should have is to be comfortable
programming that is like for me if this
is the first most important skills that
is expected from computational
scientists in this in a biotech and the
rest would vary from one company to
another and depending on the product
well thank you um yeah you know it's
it's been a while since I've been up
here and I always forget how I'm such a
small data guy by comparison so we hear
these stories about what can be done
with big data the human genome and so on
and I tend to focus on look at that
white count on patient Joe Smith so a
little little data my name's James
McCormick and I'm a graduate of OHSU and
currently I'm the director of political
diplomatic s-- at a large independent
practice Association in Bend and we
cover quite a range we're really the
whole swath of Central Oregon including
the gorge and bits of Eastern Oregon
bottom line though is that we have over
700 clinicians that are part of our IPA
and they range from tiny one doc solo
practices including a couple concierge
practices all the way up to a very large
multi specialty practice in Bend we also
are partners with st. Charles Hospital
who is not considered an independent
practice but is our partner in an
accountable care organization so a lot
of those relationships that we have
including Pacific source as both the
gorge and central Oregon's coordinated
care organization as you know the group
that takes care of our Medicaid
population means that we have a lot of
data going back and forth between our
organization and external ones and we
have to help them understand what's
going on within our membership but also
understand what's happening outside of
our membership as well at a community
level so it's a pretty big picture the
nice thing for me though is that Bend is
a pretty straightforward ecosystem we
have one large hospital there on Epic so
I've got that in one box we have a
couple large multi-specialty we've got
Greenway we've got epic again we've got
ocean three different federally
qualified health centers Bojan epic so
it kind of for me anyway starts to put
the data in different silos but
accessible silos and that's really the
challenge of a bioinformatics astir in
this case a clinical informatics is
taking all of that stuff so if you were
to go through this piece by piece this
is our strategic sort of place map that
we have you can imagine these management
retreats where everyone goes and brain
storms and comes up with this lovely
picture the bottom line is you're not
gonna see informatics up
and the reason is that at least in my
role informatics is a supportive
technology the mission of Coppa is to
help small independent practices large
independent practices manage contracts
with payers like Pacific source we don't
contract with cambia but we could and
provide what they need in order to
manage their populations to hit the
quality metrics they need to hit to be a
successful payer in addition we have
credentialing so credentialing involves
dealing with things like state provider
directory and other IT tasks quality of
course each clinic is very focused on
their own quality for various reasons
you might think MIPS measurements they
report their quality measurements and
get either an incentive or a
disincentive from the government so
there are pay for performance metrics
built into a lot of pair contracts now
that means that all of a sudden clinics
that focused patient by patient are
moving into the world of having to
manage a population and you'll hear
population health mentioned over and
over again so in in my world what that
means is having enough data to be able
to know what's going on in your
population and then hopefully start to
take that data and be more proactive and
I'll talk about that in just a minute
because it's pretty much the most
exciting thing going on right now at
coiba more on that in just a minute
so again informatics is definitely a
supportive technology and I I don't want
to forget the day-to-day workflow a
provider capturing a blood pressure in
the office it's doing a health screening
form for risky alcohol use all of those
things can be informatics tasks each
clinic may approach them in a different
way with a different workflow at a
different set of forms they're going to
have different EHRs they might have a
different instance of the same EHR
multiple epics they might have it hosted
by someone like ocean where there's some
commonality across sites or they could
have built their EHR in a completely
different way and I look across my 13 in
clinical work sites within the IPA and
every one of them has built their system
in a different way even though they're
trying to address some of the same
challenges on quality reporting of
population health so the variety of
members that we have and the IT
platforms that they support within their
clinics is a real challenge to do it
what we really want to do which is
across region population health so more
on this this gets a little more into the
tactics for those strategies now we
start to get into a little bit more
informatics you'll see down on the
little corner there
eh arson Alice's where we go into the
clinic's and help them use their EHRs
better EHR optimization and this is a
big one
um we cannot do a CCO measure so right
now there's a new CCO measure that
requires clinics that see Medicaid
patients to report alcohol and drug risk
assessments so it's a nice little
quality measure it's got a number to
numbers actually but it's very hard to
get from the EHRs because of the way
they've configured the data capture
workflows so a lot of what we do in the
optimization unfortunately is retro
actively setting those systems up or
configuring them so they can meet the
current demands of the government and
their payers and those of you who track
MIPS and formerly Meaningful Use know
that those bars change year after year
so it's a moving target so one of the
challenges for us is to try to align the
work that we do and not just follow the
bouncing ball or they're kind of the
next shiny light which would be oh look
mips just changed something patient
Center medical home meets this new
report our clinics have to do UDS
reporting for this new thing we have to
do those things but we try to be
strategic and right now we can't do that
because our challenge is that this data
lives in a bunch of separate silos as I
mentioned now there are some neat things
we can do if you hire a PhD in format
assist you would expect that you can
extract data from an EHR we do that you
can dump it into a new database and
analyze it we do that but to get back to
a you know dr. Vuckovich point it has to
solve a problem and it has to be
sustainable and I'm glad you mentioned
that word because it's right in our
mission statement we have to be able to
provide sustainable services we're
funded off the contracts work that we do
the credentialing business were in and
membership dues so we have a limited
amount of resources that we can spend
doing things and it's got to align with
a bigger picture and that strategy has
to be sustainable so for me to extract
data from
13 different eClinicalWorks systems and
dump it into an Access database which I
do because it was my only option at the
time he's not sustainable so what do we
do the exciting thing that we're doing
now is we have just selected a vendor of
choice for a population health analytics
tool specifically for the IPA and we've
worked with the larger of our members
starting with the Medicaid just because
of the CCO priorities in the region to
feed those data into a more robust
population health tool that goes above
and beyond what an individual analyst
could possibly do on their own in
addition it starts to get us into more
of a proactive or predictive mode if you
start looking at what the population
health vendors out there are offering
much of it is retrospective analytics
can I report my quality measures based
on the HR or claims data sure you can
but the real value there is being able
to apply algorithms and predictive
analytics to try to identify patients
who are at higher risk for certain
conditions and then take that data back
to the clinic in a way that they can act
on it
so we're suddenly in this weird position
of having more data than we can handle
we're five years ago we were all whining
because we couldn't get data out of EHRs
so it's a good position to be in but at
least in my position as an analyst and
not a data scientist is I tend to hit my
limits so I look out at this group and
Ted and I have talked about this before
is that difference between someone who's
a data scientist so I want to describe a
little bit of how I differentiate that
you know there are real formal
definitions for this but I as an analyst
can work with clinicians and payers and
come up with the questions to ask
thanks to OHSU and Cerner to some extent
I am trained to query data so I have the
technical stills skills to be able to
crudely extract and analyze data where a
data scientist would add to this is the
ability to know what questions to ask
now we have a medical director who's
very very fluent in informatics she's
very smart about this she knows what
questions she wants to know but I think
as you all know there's a reality check
where what stories can the data truly
tell you
as opposed to what you hope you can get
from just aggregating a bunch of bits
and bytes and there's a big Delta and so
I see your role isn't from at assists is
being able to not just do the work of
aggregating cleaning and presenting data
but being able to help stakeholders like
clinicians and payers to find that not
only the questions they want to ask but
also the things that the data can really
tell you now I look at Nicole here
because I know she studied this the data
quality we get for a lot of reasons
coming from EHRs is not great and and I
could do a whole talk on that but the
end point is the payers expect us to be
able to use it I'll just give a quick
example how will I know if a patient's
a1c is under control
payers not going to know that from
claims data gonna know if an a1c got
done they're not gonna know what the
value is so everybody has to have this
this data so then we decide that we're
technically able to pull the data out of
the EHRs and combine it we're done right
not so much what about point of care a1
C's are those captured and stored in the
same way in the EHR some yes some no
what about a1c is that never get back to
the clinic that might be done by a
commercial lab or sent as a PDF or a
document can't mine that stuff either at
least yet I know
smart people are working on that so the
challenges of knowing the data at the
source and helping stakeholders
understand what those data can really
tell you is a big chunk of what I do and
I've used the word and it's not very
popular magical thinking we're going to
get this great platform we're going to
turn on all these interfaces and we're
going to be showered with usable
insights fact is that we already know
from our work with the a cos population
health their challenges there too so as
informaticists I think there are four
things you really need to know you need
to understand the technology of course
the mechanics how to do it but you also
need to understand the the clinical
aspect how are these data really
captured what is the workflow of doing a
risky alcohol screen
how are those data captured is it a form
is it discrete data in India HR and if
it is how do I get it and then
translating that into what the
stakeholders really need for actionable
insights so I'm very excited about this
I'll mention that the vendor we chose is
is Arcadia we looked at a number of
vendors that was very interesting
process in just understanding what they
can and can't offer and I will tell you
that the Holy Grail and this kind of
goat speaks back to both of our other
panelists is being able to combine data
from multiple sources what we really
want to be able to do is gather insights
both from the claims data and from the
clinical data in one box if you will and
be able to take that back to the clinics
and drive practice change and none of
those things are easy and that's all I
have because I get to go first
have to do you've already addressed some
of you and I'm generally just putting
this out there when you consider a
candidate for hired or your organization
what skills and traits do you focus on
and what you consider essential I know
dr. Soleri talked about that and went
what also do you sometimes find lacking
or maybe often find lacking and in terms
of a skill set or a trait set with
candidates whoever wants to start okay
oh yeah we've kind of touched on the big
ones I mean the technical is obvious
you've got to be able to wrangle data
got it clinical workflow I mentioned
industry understanding industry and
under industry I would put the business
of this when you're looking at six
different population health vendors and
you worked at Cerner for 13 years as I
did you know the vendor tricks you know
what's going to be shown and not shown
in a demonstration you know how to write
a request for information to get what
you need to make a good decision that
industry knowledge is not easy to come
by
so knowing
how the industry works when you're
engaged with industry partners is
important also other stakeholders
understanding what the pressures are on
a coordinated care organization we're a
unique state that the CCOs are given
free rein to do what they need to do
with Medicaid provided they meet certain
metrics they've committed to CMS they've
got to hit those metrics that's serious
stuff and the CCOs themselves are
actually paid an incentive based on
their ability to hit metrics that's
going to be a really key important thing
for them to understand for Medicare
Advantage programs the star ratings are
hugely important as a clinician seeing
somebody for a sore throat I'm not
necessarily thinking about star ratings
but when I think about my contract with
a payer paid for form for performance
schemes how that payer is going to
distribute those incentives which the
CCOs do that becomes important so making
that connection with how the finances of
healthcare work and how it influences
the priorities of different stakeholders
all along the way I would say ethics
there's a lot of discussion right now
going on with basically freeing the data
which sounds terrific
but the the 21st century cures Act which
potentially could require providers to
release their data via api's to anyone
who asks for it with the patient's
permission now I won't go into the pros
and cons there but a lot of us feel that
there are some ethical concerns with
moving that into the app space and out
of the HIPAA controlled environment
that's currently there which is
certainly not perfect but ethics
understanding the regulations
understanding why I can't just go into a
clinic and download 2,000 patient a1c
records on a flash drive and walk away
with it I need to know about what their
constraints are and then finally the
soft and communication and collaboration
skills cannot stress those enough and
dr. Joe Nash and her course talks about
Bridgers people who live in multiple
worlds and as somebody with an advanced
degree in informatics you are those
people you get the clinicians
constraints but you also understand the
technology and can give them reality
so what do people miss I think they tend
to be overly focused on one of the
domains I just mentioned they might be
superstars technically they can script
anything but they don't have a feel for
the source data or they don't have an
interest in digging into where that data
is coming from and how its captured so I
think it's that big picture we're a
small organization so I don't have a
business analyst that only does quality
measures I'm kind of that person a
bigger organization might have people
that could be that specialized we don't
and so it's really important that I am
able to communicate with our
stakeholders and our practices and the
state on why these things are hard and
why our clinics are having a hard time
providing them I have to speak for those
clinics that's hard for a pure
technologist to do thank you I'll just
wear that I think that you know in our
organization I mentioned some of the the
soft as well as hard skills that we look
for as well as I wear I think employment
in general is moving and the kind of
information workers that we all are the
skill sets we need to have I would say
though that while domain knowledge and
knowledge of the industry is important
particularly as people move into more
senior positions when we're looking at
entry-level I would say that the ability
ability and willingness to think on your
feet and to learn as you go is really
important so to not just assume that you
know the answers but begin to develop
networks and understand who it is you
need to go to ask for clarity about what
a regulation is or what the process is
would be very important
I yeah I'm gonna have to talk about this
entry that's what I asked you
so again like for me because I we are
hiring like technical people and this is
a very technical team and I hired
already many many searches about being a
precious student I actually consider it
as like a positive thing it's not
something negative for me and I already
mentioned that I want them to be really
really good at programming that is a
must-have there is no conversation okay
about that but I don't think is that I
think is missing and I think freshers
student should be aware of is that it's
okay to not know much about industry it
is totally okay you guys spend all of
your life for so many many years you
learned how to do how to write papers
it's okay if you don't know how to do QA
for yourself
it's okay you can learn it but from the
very beginning from the moment that you
go for interview and you start your job
mm-hmm you need to be aware of that that
you you're coming with the big
experience on one shoulder and the other
shoulder is empty you should be aware of
that and you should be open for learning
you shouldn't think that oh you know
what I was the best PhD student in my oh
yeah I'm I'm gonna be the best now I
have to be manager of a team and know
there is a lot of experience that you
you need to give it time you're so young
and so many years ahead of you and be
very very open to the learning process
that whole things in industry work how
like for example if you want to build a
product that has x and y and z
requirement
one of the steps and it's totally okay
if I'm day number one you don't know
anything about it but just be open
because in a year it's not okay to not
know a great advice thank you all and
you've covered the three questions I had
so on that note I'm gonna open it up to
anybody who would like to ask a question
sorry this might be a little bit more
technical but I'm always interested in
how you this is what James the you
mentioned that you essentially collected
information from multiple different
clinics throughout the whole region and
for me that's always a tricky issues
because everyone's running a different
system and I don't know how many EHRs
you have to deal with probably six
different vendors right and you have to
map every single data piece is that
something that you do personally or like
how do you approach that yes and it's
not sustainable yes it can't be done
indefinitely
the good news is there's some standard
content in most EHRs so my
eClinicalWorks systems I can sort of
group those and then map them as a group
and that's true with sno-med codes and
ICDs and CPT so there are standard code
sets that I pull from that are pretty
consistent across sites but just to give
you one example the problem list of
Athena uses sno-med problem lists any
clinical works an epic uses ICD so yes
combining those data sets is very labor
intensive and quite frankly on the tools
that I have available I've just
graduated to tableau which is wonderful
but it's not a scripting language there
are techniques that I could be using
that I don't know
all right so short answer is it's wicked
hard and if these population health
vendors can help solve that that's why
they're getting the big bucks are you
thinking about it is any plan to I guess
expand it to make it more of our
standard way to approach this or do you
know if there's any it's tough I mean a
lot of people say that if we were if
everyone in the world were on epoch we'd
be better off because the backend data
model in the front-end workflows would
be pretty consistent and and we knew
where that data was coming from that's a
world that's far far away other people
say that we need a standard
to our data model that all vendors
should use they're not going to
reconstruct the products from the ground
up on some you know academic data model
that somebody developed so I think we're
stuck this is the world we're in the
good news though is with epic success
there's a lot of consolidation Oregon is
almost a hundred percent epic in its
large health systems that's a good thing
it means that there's still variability
in the data but we can approach
extracting the data in the same way it's
a hard problem and I wish there were a
magic solution that'll be ism thank you
unless can be is found I guess this is
for everybody what would you say are
like the top one into pros and cons of
working in industry I can give you one I
I mentioned Cerner so before I came to
OHSU I was an executive at Cerner for 13
years so I was in industry then before
that another software company so I I got
a snoot full of Industry and it helps me
everyday in understanding what our
clinics have to face on the other hand
though it was a different lifestyle I
think the biggest Pro was the variety
the fact that you're in a commercial
world you have a different set of
priorities but you have to align those
with what your customers need so you're
going to a different clinic a different
hospital every week potentially every
other day the learning from that is
tremendous so you get exposure to the
worldwide IT world the downside is
lifestyle it's hard and especially if
you're in a traveling role that was
brutal I know and it wears on people so
I think that not into all industries
like that but when I think of working
for a health IT vendor a lot of those
roles are traveling and a lot of those
are hard on you I had the next question
and I'll be putting you all on spot and
ask directly if anybody is interested in
doing internships with you or you have
current job opportunities was the best
way to approach you I of course
I didn't I don't have cards making my
email addresses available and I know
that cambia does offer internships
what's available in informatics I'm not
aware of at the moment but that could be
found out
both internship time jobs are available
I put the link for for a higher you can
go apply for full-time positions over in
to enter the link that is Nasr that come
slash care and for internship email me
one more question
sorry monopolizing the time James I'm
really interested in the data sets that
you have and if a student wants to use
that what's the process like the process
would be rewriting our data use
agreements because for HIPAA reasons
they were as you can imagine these
clinics are very reluctant to give a
third party even someone they pay like
an IPA to come in and access all their
data I'll also mention that in order to
calculate six of the CCO metrics last
year I had to pull problem lists you
name it so that's a lot of very
sensitive data we specifically said it
would not be used for research having
said that though if you had a unique
need for a data set and you were willing
in the clinic we're willing to provide
that if they're an IPA clinic we could
help you get to it but unfortunately
none of this wonderful data could be
used to research at this point because
we've excluded it thank you it is out
there though and it is accessible
amazing talks doctor Solaria had this
question for you how is signature our
personalized like how are you getting
that
I understand its care detecting
circulating tumor DNA but how do you
make it like personalized you like
individual people so when we wanted to
have a test that works for most of the
patients we did it research for one year
and we realized that cancer is a very
very random process mutations that
happen in cancer they're very different
from a patient to another yes there are
some hottest but mutations known for for
example for like breast cancer or for
colon cancer but truly the hottest pot
is just one or two mutations and it
doesn't cover most of their patients so
we realize that if you want to if you
want to build a marker that works for
cancer patients we need to build this
market based on the various specific
mutations that each patient has how do
we do it we do this we get a biopsy from
the from the tumor we perform whole
exome sequencing we analyze it and we
identify variants and the Nok tumor it's
specific to that tumor and then we build
our assay internally we we save that I
say somewhere in our lab and put the
name of not the name idea of that
patient on the outside so every time
we're gonna use this assay for that
patient this is a will not work for any
other patient and just because it's
truly personalized that's why it gives
us a very low limit of detection so this
is going to remain like a lab based test
in future there might be a possibility
of like a home detection the patient can
just have it and like you know like how
you do a glucose diabetes testing right
so I think it can be it can be but in I
don't know how thank you very happy
and then how does your model address any
sporadic mutations within a cancer
genome if you are tracking someone over
time if the underlying genetics of the
cancer may have some Janek drills how
does how do you validate your probes all
right time so the hypothesis is that the
hypothesis of cancer evolution is that
it usually starts from like a one or two
special mutation and it just go and get
more and more mutations I don't know if
any of you studied cancer evolution or
heard about cancer phylogeny but we can
can for each tumor cancer tumors right
we can imagine a phylogeny that it
starts from very specific mutations it
can be assemblies in those or the
enemies whatever and then over time it
just scatters more and more and more
mutations the way that our algorithm for
violent selection choose we just try to
find those top ones and follow those top
ones so we we know that if you're
following two ones right and we should
be always like at the source to be able
to find this city DNA because supposedly
all the cancer cells they have those
mutations right it is possible that
treatment kills some of the branches
some of the mutations but if a treatment
kills the top top salt
it means cancer is over
thank you all so much for coming and
sharing your information and advice with
[Applause]